do you all remember when liberals went
nuts when they found out that George W
Bush when he was a candidate for the
presidency was a member of skull and
bones Chris Cohen bones
it's that Yale University super
mysterious Club that was founded in 1832
it's really creepy well it turns out
that according to an informant
anti-trump FBI investigator Peter Strock
and his gal pal FBI lawyer Lisa Paige
spoke in text messages about a secret
society within the within the FBI itself
that would convene apparently off-site
presumably I don't know to discuss
things like insurance policies and other
benevolent matters involving Donald
Trump well Senator Ron Johnson today was
flabbergasted at what he learned what
this is all about is further evidence of
corruption more than bias but corruption
at the highest levels of the FBI in that
secret society we have we have an
informant that's talking about a group
they were holding secret meetings
off-site there's there's so much smoke
here there's so much suspicion are there
similar individuals highly biased
political operatives burrowed into the
Department of Justice as well
well you combine this with the suddenly
missing five months of texts between the
two lovebirds and you do have a
full-blown corruption scandal on your
hands involving the very people who were
leading the investigation into both mrs.
Clinton's private email server and the
Russia collusion nonsense involving
Trump I have a question how are heads
not already rolling just knowing what we
know now well I'm not radio show this
morning former US Attorney Joe digenova
he made the case that this all indicates
that we need a big change of leadership
at the FBI and at the Justice Department
quite apparent that Christopher Rea is
not up to the job of being FBI director
that he is undermining its credibility
not strengthening it
and that he is completely completely
controlled by the upper bureaucracy at
the FBI the other real problem is rot
residence time and I don't think there
is any any any doubt whatsoever that
Rosen Stein is too close to Comey too
close to Muller too close to Rea they're
too close to a whole bunch of people
yes sessions seems to have decided that
if he can have a little bit of fun
within the goal you know within the
boundaries of the playing field and not
get anybody mad at him that's going to
be enough to get the job done it was
ugly it was brutal and I have to say the
American public has a right to know what
if any crimes or other improprieties
were committed by members of the Obama
administration and members of the
current FBI but I have to tell you the
bleeding this has got to stop now in the
DOJ and the FBI they have to be purged
of anyone actively working to undermine
the Trump administration with a
political agenda of course and be purged
of anyone who refused to remove those or
report those committing this type of
wrongdoing who's serving from the
government they shouldn't be serving the
government at all and I'm not talking
you know just don't transfer them to
another office
they must be fired and now onto
Schumer's revenge
there were brief moments in the lead-up
to the government shutdown last week
when Chuck Schumer's seemed to be coming
to his senses on maybe the issue of the
wall well here he was on Friday in
exchange for strong dacha protections I
reluctantly put the border wall on the
table for discussion even that was not
enough to entice the president to finish
the deal now it was been announced that
huckster chuck is taking border wall
funding off the table and in immigration
policy negotiation says this man totally
lost his line I mean he just had his
political clock clean for this
ridiculous government shutdown that got
him nothing and now he's going to take
away the one immigration must-have for
Republicans in the White
I don't think so oh and as for the
moronic flake Graham Durbin bill that
Trump nixed last week and that all led
remember to to Schumer shutting down the
government and that big hissy fit two
weeks ago we outlined a path forward on
four issues serious border security and
into chain migration the cancellation of
the outdated and unsafe Visa Lottery and
a permanent solution to daca
unfortunately the flake Graham Durbin
agreement does not meet these benchmarks
in fact it would not secure our border
encourage more illegal immigration
increase chain migration and retain the
visa lottery system in short it's
totally unacceptable to the President
and should be declared dead on arrival
oh I love hearing dead on arrival when
it comes to a bad immigration bill
building the border wall was not just
the president's signature campaign issue
it's what the American people want
remember that new Harvard Harris Poll we
told you about last night a lot of
people haven't focused on this it showed
that 61% of those surveyed feel border
security today is inadequate 54% of
respondents want a wall or other barrier
built across the u.s. Mexican border
couldn't be clearer and while Americans
do want to help the doc of people I
guess and give some kind of protection
to them they don't want to be left
defenseless to do it that makes sense
look Chuck Schumer is under enormous
pressure these days a host of left-wing
interest groups are insisting that he
resists the President and fight him on
everything including immigration now why
they doing this because they want to see
the dawn of a new governing majority and
it's coming across the border
in the spring of next year we're gonna
talk about this later on with Coulter
California will begin automatically
registering any adult who obtains or
renews a driver's license to vote in the
state now California has been granting
driver's licenses to illegal since 2015
Fox News estimates that a million
illegal immigrants already have secured
a license to drive in the Golden State
this is by the end of last year so now
turning them into instant voters is sure
to change the outcome it
now it's a supermajority in that state
for Democrats but still that is shocking
and speaking of these issues that the
President and so many of us and I know
so many of you really care about you
hear a lot about chain migration but I
thought it was really important for you
to understand what it is how it
transforms the country and why it must
end also part of the Trump must-haves on
immigration this is a White House
graphic that we share with you
exclusively tonight you can see it for
every hour the United the u.s. settles
enough migrants to fill a small
auditorium that's really small print
isn't it every day enough to fill a
large high school every month we
resettle enough to fill an entire
football stadium to capacity every year
an immigrant population larger than the
size of Washington DC every year we
resettle a 174,000 parents a
foreign-born naturalized citizens now
remember most of those are older elderly
they're not going to be paying into a
lot of taxes they're gonna be taking a
lot of services though now they're so
they're paying basically nothing into
the system once they're naturalized they
immediately qualify for all the welfare
programs benefits so basically you pay
for their retirement
that's a nice deal if you can get it and
all of this probably why will and that
Harvard Harris Poll 65 to 35 percent of
Americans support a daca deal that ends
chain migration eliminates the Visa
Lottery and secures the border wall 79
percent of the people in the same poll
want immigration based on merit not
family ties so 79 percent agree with the
president it's time for the Democrats to
start putting the hopes and dreams of
the American people first it is now
crystal clear that Schumer and the
Democrats are gonna run over the
American worker and risk their safety if
that's what it takes to tilt local and
national elections in their favor and
that's the angle